hold that fork ida ladies and gentlemen
it is time to find out what the
rutherfords have
been doing
yeah this is sort of a musical
newsletter don't worry it's quick
oh no no no it's great all right my
family doesn't even speak to each other
all right uncle roger drop a beat
yeah one of these years raj all right
here we go
well a banner year it turned out to be
for the mighty
rutherford clan a swim team championship
for carly and a haircut
for dan emma saved a stranger's life a
heimlich
to the chest uncle jake went to nepal
on a spiritual quest cousin beth got
married
to a delawarean named steve who got
a big promotion vp at allstate i believe
how fast did he know that oh he does his
research mental note take a car or boat
to visit ken and randy i heard from your
son that you've begun
to make your own pear brandy we have
it is gross yeah oh he mentioned that
well old joe is off the market it's
strange to say those words
i must have it twisted he's always
insisted that love is
for the birds it is for the birds
all right i love being part of this
family oh we're glad to have you steve
oh man i love this i love this tradition
you guys have i love this house
ah can't believe you're selling it larry
[Music]
to the rutherfords i'm sorry
uh what what did he say it's
dry
[Music]